hey yo theo i'm calling him from
virginia
uh i just want to start by saying i love
everything that you and your whole crew
do everything from this past weekend to
the fighter and the kid the tiger belly
tiger pit i love all you guys
oh thank you and this is a young fella
this is a ginger gentleman right here
um and his name larry ritchie
go on brother but my question comes this
week from
uh the fact i grew up with grandparents
and they've always been behind the times
and i've
always felt like that wore off on me you
know and i started watching you guys
show at the beginning of the pandemic to
try and get an
idea of like you know like this is
what's normal you know
and uh but i still feel like i'm really
in the dark about everything so
um i guess my question for you is how do
someone stay informed
during these times you know uh
to everything that's really going on all
right stay safe out there
gang gang larry i appreciate that man
how do you stay informed and he had a
dog
at the end there that felt uncomfortable
you could hear a little bit of that
let's go back and listen to that dog
really going on all right stay safe out
there
gang gang and let's hear the dog one
more time uh
to everything that's really going on
so well first of all you got to listen
to that animal
if you got an animal in front of you
it's going through a tough time man you
need to do something
put your fingers in its mouth or put
your fingers in your mouth brother
uh thank you for calling larry and
sending this video how do you stay
informed i think you gotta just trust
your instincts
that's one thing that i think we're
getting back to
the news has jumped the shark the news
isn't even as reliable as the most
ignorant person you knew they have some
video and audio proof that's it
but i think a lot of it is just trusting
your instincts
and it's almost kind of nice that the
news has burnt itself out
you know it's almost kind of nice
because it's like oh okay here's
something else
here's something that i that i know i
don't need
i believe that if people if you're
really if you were making a point to get
that news all the time
we have to be careful that we're not
just getting it to fire us up
because i noticed it for myself man last
week i got into it and
it fires me up
but it's not my fire
i'm that i'm transporting somebody
else's heat
you know i'm just uh it's i'm not
and i think you know and also just
listening to yourself check in with
yourself
focus on your surroundings see what's
going on
you know that's how you stay informed
man i think getting you know
the the thing we really need to listen
to the most right now is ourselves
you know i do believe that our hearts
will lead us into the best that
that's the best the best msnbc is right
in the middle of our chest man
listen to your heart remember that song
baby
listen to your heart
there's always that like big jack dude
that gets up at karaoke
and he's all he always will get but
listen to your heart
it's what i wanted you to do listen to
your heart
and people are like damn this guy
is gonna be lonely for a long time baby
thank you larry richie
for hitting us with that beautiful
visual man he's sending a video man
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah